SHUTDOWN.
THERE ARE STILL SOME MAJOR
ISSUES UNRESOLVED.
CHEAP CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPOND
WITH MIKE EMANUEL TELLS US WHAT
THEY ARE.
>> CONGRESSES FACING A FRIDAY
NIGHT DEADLINE ON ITS
$1.3 TRILLION SPENDING PACKAGE
AND ALREADY THE HOUSE IS
EXPECTING THE VOTE ON THURSDAY.
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND E
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND T
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND N
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND D
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND O
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND R
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND W
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND E
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND K
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND I
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND T
>> IT WILL OVEREXTEND O
THE WEEKEND PERHAPS FOR THIS
SHOWS WHY THIS IS REALLY A
TERRIBLE WAY TO HAVE TO DO
BUSINESS, WHERE THE FINAL
DECISIONS ARE LEFT OF THE
FOUR PEOPLE.
>> THAT'S A REFERENCE TO THE BIG
FOUR LEADERS OF CONGRESS.
McCONNELL, SCHUMER, RYAN, AND
PELOSI.
THEY EXPRESSED OPTIMISM THEY'LL
BE ABLE TO PASS THE BILL.
THE TEXT OF THE LEGISLATION WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ANNOUNCED LAST
NIGHT TO SET THE STAGE FOR A
HOUSE BOAT FOR YOU TO SPEAK AT
WE GOT CLOSE BUT WE WEREN'T
GOING TO LET MIDNIGHT STOP US
FROM FINISHING OUR JOB OF
NEGOTIATING IT OUT.
>> AMONG THE FINAL ISSUES,
COST-SHARING REDUCTIONS FOR
OBAMACARE WHICH DEMOCRATS HAVE
WANTED.
AND THE ONGOING STRUGGLE OVER
ADDRESSING THE SO-CALLED
DREAMERS IN EXCHANGE FOR BORDER
WALL FUNDING.
BUT TOP DEMOCRATS SAY BOTH SIDES
ARE FAR APART ON DACA AND BORDER
SECURITY.
>> WE'LL KEEP FIGHTING AND
TRYING.
THE COURTS HAVE GIVEN SOMETHING
OF A REPRIEVE BUT THEY WILL BE
LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
HELP THE DACA KIDS.
>> ANOTHER CONCERN, THE RISK OF
A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN DUE TO
MOTHER NATURE'S INCLEMENT
WEATHER.
BUT SO FAR, THE SENATE AND A
MAJORITY LEADER DOESN'T APPEAR
TO BE WORRIED PRETTY >> WHAT MY
FOCUSES FINISHING THIS OMNIBUS
APPROPRIATION WHICH WILL FUND
THE GOVERNMENT TO THROUGH
SEPTEMBER 30TH AND WE WILL DO IT
THIS WEEK.
>> THERE'S ALSO PRESSURE ON THE